le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais dans notre
quotidien
il n'est pas rare de croiser des
personnes porteuses de handicap
elles sont 38 milles à la réunion que
leur handicap soit physique ou mentale
ces personnes font leur maximum pour
s'intégrer au fonctionnement de la
société
cependant comment facilitons nous leur
vie quels sont les moyens mis en oeuvre
pour les aider
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
farid est un jeune artiste qui veut
s'imposer dans le monde de la musique
réunionnaise porteurs de handicap
il nous explique que les portes des
studios se ferment régulièrement devant
lui mon objectif dans la vie c'est de
déjà de réussir musicalement devait
devenir chanteur professionnel et aussi
en parallèle devenir aussi infographiste
dans le cas de mon handicap je n'ai
jamais eu de souci particulier qu'ils
soient dans ma vie personnelle
professionnelle mais dans le cas de
musicale oui ça m'a toujours posé un
problème car on n'est pas souvent
acceptée est prise au sérieux
on est handicapé encore manquons des
jeunes artistes c'est pour ça aussi ça
appelle aussi à tous les gens à tous les
boîtes de production de boîtes de nuit
de manifestants pour tous qui d'une
manifestation scène et ou d'essayer de
d'ouvrir la scène à tout le monde et
décidé d'arrêter aussi de regarder le
côté anti cas car malgré un handicap on
ne chante pas avec le fauteuil mais avec
sa bouche
e
fin d'éveiller les consciences et
permettre aux personnes handicapées de
découvrir les différents moyens mis en
place par le conseil général le 1er juin
au jardin de l'état se tiendra la 2e
journée départementale de la personne
handicapée
une journée pour tous accessible à tous
et pleine de surprises
une journée placée notamment sous le
signe de l'art et de la culture
farid lui aussi sera de la partie et
vous fera découvrir son talent et ses
compositions dans le cadre du conseil
général j'ai été invité le premier
adjoint à une manifestation jardin de
l'état qui va se dérouler avec l' air
productions un concert d'une heure c'est
ma avec plein d'artistes comme lise en j
ai encore plein d'autres encore qui
participe aussi sur cet album là je
repars est accompagné aussi de mon dj dj
ryan qui est aussi mon manager aussi
actuellement dans ce cas de la madame
nassimah dindar
éviter justement à partager ma musique
avec toutes les personnes qui seront au
rendez vous le 1er juin au jardin de
l'état pour nassimah dindar ainsi que
pour l'ensemble de conseil général il
est vital que chacun trouve sa place à
la réunion
les moyens mis en place par la
présidente et ses équipes sont
considérables environ 180 millions
d'euros par an entre adaptation des
infrastructures moyens pour permettre
l'accessibilité et dispositifs divers
par exemple les personnes handicapées
peuvent se rendre dans les musées gérés
par le conseil général sans que leur
handicap soit un frein
le conseil général nous continuerons à
accompagner les personnes porteuses de
handicap pour une accessibilité aux
loisirs
le pass loisirs leur a permis nos
équipements culturels seront également
accessibles aux personnes porteuses de
handicap et beaucoup comme farid peuvent
aujourd'hui non seulement se mettre à la
musique mais également à l'art à la
sculpture à la peinture et je crois
qu'il faut non seulement aider à cette
démocratisation de la culture pour tous
mais c'est également un enrichissement
pour chacun d'entre nous que d'écouter
ces jeunes talents nouveaux à découvrir
à renouveler et je souhaite à toutes les
personnes qui veulent aujourd'hui faire
de la musique de la photo peindre de
venir au conseil général dans des
équipements à l'artothèque à la
bibliothèque départementale faire en
sorte qu' on puisse faire émerger de
nous
j'ai un conseil à donner à toutes les
personnes qui sont différents handicaps
ou pas de croire et d'avancer de
justement ne pas se laisser abattre au
premier parole des gens j'ai commencé la
musique exactement à l'âge de 10 ans
j'ai eu l'aide de monsieur nasser djoudi
et de marica social du centre
d'éducation motrice au simple usage qui
m'ont ouvert les portes qui m'ont permis
de faire pas mal de concerts hors du
département comme le grand festival
d'avignon en 2012 avec disney channel
talents et pas mal d'autres encore
manifestation pour vous dire que
l'handicap n'a jamais été un frein pour
personne encore moins pour les gens qui
souhaitent vraiment se battre dans le
milieu musical c'est juste une question
d'envié de motivation
moi je vous conseille de croire les
d'avancer sans réfléchir
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais